well once again Ireland has been front
and center of the brexit debate so let's
try and get some answers with Islands
Europeans hello
McEntee thank you very much for joining
us on the program this morning and now
we know that you don't want to we know
that you don't intend to but can you
guarantee that if there is a No Deal
there will be no hard border in Ireland
what we have done throughout this entire
process is tried to work with the EU
obviously led by Michel Barnier but with
the UK also to ensure that we never get
to the space where there is a No Deal
scenario and where we can even
contemplate any kind of a return to a
border on this island and so that is
exactly what we have been doing
negotiations have been ongoing for
months and months of this stage and we
believe that we have found the best way
to ensure thus no matter what happens no
matter what kind of a future
relationship that we have that we never
return to borders of the past the
withdrawal agreement and the backstop
within the withdrawal agreement is the
way to do that but obviously without
that our own opinion and from their
government point of view is that there
are still obligations there Briggs's or
no brags that the Good Friday Agreement
is an international peace treaty it was
signed by the Irish government by the
political parties in the north but also
the UK government and integral to that
peace treaty and ensuring that we
maintain the peace not just on this
island but we know the impact that it
had even further afield is by ensuring
that we don't have a border and I
believe that those obligations are there
and must be fulfilled irrespective of
the outcome of breakfast and I
understand that you're working hard to
try and make sure there is a deal that
you are very keen to fulfill the
obligations but I've kind of missed
whether or not there was a guarantee
that if there is a no deal there won't
be a border a hard border so if there is
a no deal scenario and you know I hope
that that's not the case I don't believe
that that will be the case we're
obviously less than 65 days ice until
the 29th of March and there will be a
number of votes taking place in
Westminster next week
however if and again if we get to a No
Deal scenario
the UK will have its obligations to the
WTO Ireland and the EU will have its
obligations to protect the single market
and the customs union but separately to
thus the Irish government and the UK
government both have obligations to
ensure that we protect the peace process
and an integral part of that is
protecting the invisible border that
essentially exists at the moment so as
far as we are concerned were not
planning for a border we have never been
planning for a border because it's
simply not something that we can
countenance there are obligations there
and again we're not asking for something
different we're not asking for something
new this has been the case from the very
beginning of the negotiations which
started at probably about two years ago
at this stage and there was a commitment
given by the Prime Minister
many many times last December again in
March when she presented her checkers
paper and as recently as last week and
so all we are asking is that those
commitments are fulfilled and I think
it's important to stress that even those
who want to leave the European Union
those who say that we should leave
without a dealer that the UK should
leave without a deal have continuously
said that they do not want to see a
border returned on this island and so I
think if we're all in agreeance there is
an onus on every single one of us but in
particular the UK because they are the
ones who are leaving to ensure that we
do not have a border on this island
the thing that I'm slightly confused
about is that if in an ideal scenario
you can't countenance having a hard
border there must be a way of avoiding
it and in which case why do we need the
backstop
well the backstop is there as an
insurance mechanism and a policy the
backstop is there because of the red
lines that the UK put down very early on
in these negotiations the UK have said
that you're leaving the cinema market or
leaving the customs union and so for us
the withdrawal agreements and the
backstop within us is the best way to
address those concerns however if we
find ourselves and again this is an if
and or' speaking hypothetically if we
find ourselves in a no deal scenario it
does not remove the obligations and the
commitment we believe that the Prime
Minister made in the joint reports and
the statements in December of 2017 a
very clear commitment was given at that
time to
sure that we avoid a border and so we
would expect the UK and the EU have been
very clear in this as well they will do
everything in their power to avoid a
hard border we will expect the UK to
live up to their obligations not just
from December 17 for this part of the
Good Friday Agreement this is not just
about trade this is not just about
customs this is not just about the
economy this is about protecting peace
on this island this is about making sure
the scenes that we saw last weekend
where a car bomb went off and Derry
where you had subsequent hoaxes and
possible threats that that does not
start happening again because again this
is not just an impact that it would have
on the island of Ireland but we know
looking back at the troubles looking
back at 20-30 years ago that it
stretched much further than that
so there is an onus and an obligation of
course it's very difficult that's why I
took 18 months to negotiate the overall
Irish backstop and what we have today
but of course if red lines were to
change if there were to be a different
approach in terms of the future
relationship then obviously it would
make things much easier in ensuring that
we never actually have to use the Irish
backstop so all that we are asking now
is that the UK fulfill the commitments
that they made not just in terms of the
the Briggs's as a whole and under their
commitments to the Irish backstop but
also to the Good Friday Agreement okay
and I think you speak very powerfully
there about the importance of making
sure that you don't go back to some of
the problems the past in Ireland with
that border and so I just wonder if I
could try and work out if there's any
compromise that you were prepared to
mate because of course Teresa may lost
that vote by 230 votes the worst defeat
of any sitting government which is quite
strong if you think about it some MPs
next week and be calling for a time
limit to the backstop or perhaps a
unilateral Ekans exit mechanism to the
backstop is that something that you
could countenance if it meant that this
deal could get over the line what to
suggest that we would compromise on the
Irish back stuff as suggesting that we
would compromise on the need and the
requirement to ensure that we protect
the piece that we've had for the past 20
years to push unilateral clause on a
backstop to
a time limit on the back stop it ceases
to become a back supper it ceases to be
a back stop it's not an insurance policy
it's not an insurance mechanism and that
is why we need it we needed to make sure
that we protect the peace and you know
while the devote might have lost by a
significant amount I absolutely don't
believe that it was purely because of
the Irish backs up I've said many times
before that I believe there were a lot
of MPs who did not agree with the the
withdrawal agreement because of the fact
that it kept them too closely tied to
the European others felt that it wasn't
close enough to the European Union
others wanted to leave with either deal
there are those who I know don't want to
leave at all and those who aren't sure
what they want yes and what we do know
however is that the people in Northern
Ireland that the political parties every
single political party bar the DUP wants
the withdrawal agreements and wants the
backstop within US citizens industry
sectors whether it's the farming
community whether its manufacturing food
and drink they all support the backstop
and we are very clear that if it becomes
time limited and if there is a
unilateral clause where the UK can pull
out on its own it ceases to be at what
it is supposed to be and that is the
insurance mechanism to protect what we
have fought so hard for on this island
for so long 20 years is not a long time
and again to go back to the weekend it
doesn't take very long to regress and to
go back to problems that we had in the
past and that is what we are trying to
avoid at all costs and I believe that's
what people in the UK want to avoid as
well I can't help thinking that there's
a bit of a contrast between the amount
of time that we spend talking about
breaks that in Ireland now and the
amount of time we spent talking about it
before the referendum and during the
campaign and I just wonder if you think
that some politicians in the UK don't we
understand the complexities of the
situation in Ireland well I would say
that I I think before the referendum
took place there probably wasn't very
much thought of Northern Ireland or
Ireland or the impact that it might have
I'm sure that there are absolutely were
MPs who understood and knew that there
would be significant consequences but
from an Irish point of view we
absolutely understood those and this is
why we don't support brides that we
don't think it is a good policy not just
a
but the impact that this can have on the
peace process before brexit even took
place our own government put together a
document a working paper to identify the
possible challenges that we felt would
arise where if brexit were to actually
happen and were to be followed through
and that's obviously since developed
it's evolved and there's a huge amount
of work done since then but we were very
clear from the outset that this would
have particularly if the UK were to
leave the single market and the customs
union extremely negative impact an
extremely negative impact on the Good
Friday Agreement
and all that is connected with that the
OEL Island economy the areas of
cooperation north and south ranging from
health to social protection to education
there's about 142 and possibly even more
but also the other integral parts of the
Good Friday Agreement including citizens
rights so there is a huge amount there's
a huge amount at stake here and this is
why we have said that we're not willing
to compromise but at the same time I
think we have compromised and throughout
this process the Irish backstop
initially was specific to Northern
Ireland's at the request of the UK it
was then extended to a UK wide customs
union so there has been compromise on
both sides but in terms of cutting it
off and having a time limit on it it
simply ceases to be what it's supposed
to be and that is an insurance policy
and mechanism okay we're out of time
thank you very much